(ominous industrial music)
♪ Everything I do I be
ten steps ahead (ten) ♪
♪ My youngin' got them bodies
she still piss in the bed ♪
♪ Keep the code of silence
don't repeat what I said (21) ♪
♪ Keep all the baloney I just
came for the bread (on God) ♪
♪ My hood known for wildin' and
I don't promote the violence ♪
♪ I done been through all the trials ♪
♪ And tribulations now I'm smilin' (21) ♪
♪ Say he wanted smoke we at
the table doin' the plottin' ♪
♪ We gon' slide with your shit up ♪
♪ Make it home 'fore you
hear the siren (big fact) ♪
♪ I'ma let them spin like
a spiral (straight up) ♪
♪ I don't got no love for
no rival (straight up) ♪
♪ Put him on the news
he went viral (pussy) ♪
♪ I took a number two
with my rifle (pussy) ♪
♪ Every car I'm in I
got the title (on God) ♪
♪ Slaughter gang I turn a
model to a hiker (big facts) ♪
♪ I know they want me dead ♪
♪ I got a Kel-Tec in this Viper (21) ♪
♪ I hit all the vibes on the
low 'cause I'm a sniper (21) ♪
♪ He don't want no
problems and it's obvious ♪
♪ Call me soft 'cause I laugh
when I body shit (on God) ♪
♪ You play hot potato with
the opps we be droppin' shit ♪
♪ Givin' out free smoke
'cause we got a lot of it ♪
♪ Try to feed the fam I was
trappin' in the cold (21) ♪
♪ Dropped a mixtape turned around
I was on the road (on God) ♪
♪ You can't give me no amount
of money for my soul (21) ♪
♪ He weren't really no robber ♪
♪ He got killed 'cause it
wasn't his role (facts) ♪
♪ MAC .90 pokin' out my Goyard (Goyard) ♪
♪ Diamond bag pokin' out my Louie V (LV) ♪
♪ Nigga fuck your Glock we
shoot big chops (big sticks) ♪
♪ .76 .308 and .223s (21 21) ♪
♪ I'ma let them spin like a spiral (21) ♪
♪ I don't got no love
for no rival (pussy) ♪
♪ Put him on the news
he went viral (pussy) ♪
♪ I took a number two
with my rifle (21 21) ♪
♪ Every car I'm in I got
the title (straight up) ♪
♪ Slaughter gang I turn a model
to a hiker (straight up) ♪
♪ I know they want me dead ♪
♪ I got a Kel-Tec in this
Viper (straight up) ♪
♪ I hit all the vibes on the low ♪
♪ 'cause I'm a sniper (straight up) ♪
♪ I make sure the beef
get Swiss cheese (21) ♪
♪ I'm from 20-East where they
killin' thieves (big facts) ♪
♪ Stones got my ears feelin'
like Christmas Eve (big facts) ♪
♪ Before you bend over baby
get on your knees (big facts) ♪
♪ Drive by jump out then
we tie-dye (21 21) ♪
♪ Say a nigga touch me
that's a lie lie (big cap) ♪
♪ She fried she fucked the gang ♪
♪ We call her five guys (five guys) ♪
♪ I'm so high I almost thought
I skydived (skydived) ♪
♪ I'ma let them spin like
a spiral (straight up) ♪
♪ I don't got no love for
no rival (straight up) ♪
♪ Put him on the news
he went viral (pussy) ♪
♪ I took a number two
with my rifle (pussy) ♪
♪ Every car I'm in I
got the title (on God) ♪
♪ Slaughter gang I turn a
model to a hiker (big facts) ♪
♪ I know they want me dead ♪
♪ I got a Kel-Tec in this Viper (21) ♪
♪ I hit all the vibes on the
low 'cause I'm a sniper (21) ♪
(ominous industrial music)